my buddy from uh fox sports who sat next
to me during uh
the friday night of the draft he did it
in nashville and then of course last
year
that was all awash but back at it in
cleveland
and we had such a great time with him
and
all of nfl network joel klatt of fox
sports back here on the rich eisen show
how are you joel
good what's up man how are you that was
a blast wasn't it that was so much fun
just
being in a draft it really was and and
you know listen
i was doing games and empty and
three-quarter empty stadiums all year
and to have the energy back
of you know football fans was incredible
and i i loved it i absolutely loved it
can't wait for this season
so we talked with you before the draft
joel and you were
uh head scratching uh over the justin
fields evaluation
that um that had him out of the mix
in san francisco where them staring at
either mac jones and trey lance we found
out it was trey lance and
who knows if mac jones was even involved
at any point either
because we had kyle shanahan a week ago
on in this very spot actually
on this show joel so and he said it was
lance pretty much
all along now fields is uh
a chicago bear they traded up to get him
do you like
the way it all worked out for justin
fields in the end
joel well i listen i think that when you
can go to a team
that you know granted has has struggled
the last couple of years but i would say
defensively they're they're ready to go
i think every quarterback would have
if they were to pick their destination
regardless of of you know
what they have said lawrence wilson
lance
jones fields all of them would have
picked the 49ers wouldn't you agree
they're the most ready team for a young
quarterback to go in and contribute and
potentially
go on and have a lot of success early in
his career
um but having said that i i thought that
the bears were a good
you know consolation prize if you will
for justin fields now he's he's not
going to get the
what was it 10 12 million dollars that
before goes not being that third pick
but i thought it was a good spot for him
and and i know that that city is excited
i was
texting some people on their staff
they're excited about justin
i i didn't understand the the criticisms
of justin fields in particular because i
did so many of his games now i might
have been too close to it
uh rich as as you know but boy
that type of skill set doesn't come
along every
so often the the arm strength the
accuracy the
ability to avoid turnovers the ability
to create with his feet
that to have the athleticism that he
does
and yet when he escapes the pocket his
eyes stay up there's all these things
that we would have normally just fawned
over
and then this year all of a sudden it
was just like i don't know about him
like
i don't know about him what are we
talking about
exactly and now uh we had nagi on the
show
just last week and i asked him the plan
and
he said the plan is essentially to uh
replicate
what he saw in kansas city with patrick
mahomes and the ability to have alex
smith start
all regular season games but the last
one because
they'd already secured a position in the
playoffs and and reed wanted to get his
young
charge uh uh a wet beak going into the
off season
and i i was i shot him straight i i
basically told him i don't think he's
going to have the
the luxury of that uh i i don't think
that's going to happen
um that's exactly what i would have said
and that's a good response right
because that's well and good you know
what does tyson say everyone's got a
plan until they get punched in the face
it's like wait until those bears fans
you know start seeing anemic offense and
a struggling theme
game five and they're like okay like
let's go
we want to see the kid let's rock um so
i think that that's all the wait i'll
wait and see i could see him playing
much earlier
here's the thing is i just don't want to
doubt this guy um
and and part of this rich i think that
and this is the element that i think i'm
fortunate i saw him
his like second or third practice at
ohio state like right after the transfer
and i went up to a spring ball and you
know
coach day was had just taken over from
coach meyer
and i was standing with him on the
sideline and we were watching just in
practice
and and i i'll be very honest both of us
were like boy this is a work in progress
you know and i was like and i walked
away from that practice
and i don't know if you're going to
remember this maybe you will maybe
probably not
i actually picked michigan in the
preseason that year before
ohio state's outstanding year i knew
ohio state was loaded but i had
major questions about justin from what i
saw in that spring practice
and then he comes out i did seven of
their games that year and i saw the
development
i saw this kid get better and part of
that development was
his desire to be better his desire to
play from the pocket his desire to play
um quality efficient football
as any other quarterback would he didn't
turn the football over and i was
in i came away so impressed from the
development that i saw from his first
you know third spring practice if you
will uh all the way until
you know that his last game which was
the national championship game and the
the performance against clemson the
semifinal so
i had the luxury of seeing that and so i
don't want to
bet against this guy you know they can
have all the best plans in the world
about letting him sit and this or that
but i can tell you right now that no
defensive coordinator is going to want
to see justin fields
on the field uh this season because of
everything that he brings
joel klatt here on the rich eisen show
and you're taking a look at all the
quarterbacks that got drafted
okay and you can't i think the only ones
where you could pretty much
say that they won't be on the field week
one
right now for sure obviously there's
situations where
maybe maybe not that you could sit here
and say they won't be on the field week
one
that you could say for sure would be
kyle trask right cause you know brady's
gonna be on week one
and i guess maybe even kellan monde
right because we're assuming that's
obviously you know it's it's it's kirk
cousins there
but even with davis mills even with ian
book i'm not gonna sit here and say that
he's not gonna go into
training camp and maybe wow some people
that that's a very infinitesimal odd
though that he would be on week one for
the saints would you agree with that
assessment or
or i i would i would even take it
a step further and and again i don't
think you're suggesting that these
players
will start correct it's just that you
can't say that they definitely won't
is that what you're saying yes sir that
is the construct of the
question so to me it's only one and
that's trask
and maybe i like i get it with the
vikings but you know does
can you i mean who knows with kell and
mom
i don't think that the vikings are
totally married to cousins
in that respect now having said that i
think that that's a
very low probability and i'm not
suggesting that cousins should be sat
down by any stretch but
if you're just sitting here and you're
saying like you've got to bet your
mortgage
traffic is is really the only one that
you're like yeah that's a
that's a just a no-brainer safe bet
every everybody else i think at least
has the opportunity to go into a camp
and compete for playing time now whether
that's going to happen or not is it is a
different
uh suggestion so monde would be the next
guy
probably book the next guy and then
everybody else has a shot including
and this is the one that you were you
know
so emphatic about but davis mills you
know
mills to the texans i thought was
quietly
you know the most impactful telling pick
in the entire draft well i mean because
we also had
david shaw on last week as well joel and
he said the kid
is is particularly attuned and
um wired to handle whatever comes the
way with the texans in deshaun watson's
situation as we refer to it in the media
he obviously is going to pound the table
for his own quarterback but he thinks
that
that um that mills is wired for whatever
may come his way and can actually
succeed in the nfl because of it
i really wish that he would have stayed
uh at stanford
now i'm a college guy um and and i hope
it works out for him
but i i do think that this is the type
of guy that could have had i mean how
many times now how can we
see this where a guy who's a middle
round draft pick to late ground draft
pick
if he comes out stays the joe burrows of
the word the world the baker mayfield
the kyler murrays of the world you look
at uh this year
with with zach wilson mac jones
and then all of a sudden they rock it up
with a great year i think davis mills
was that for next year and
and what i would consider a weak
quarterback class i think he was going
to be a top 15 maybe top 10 maybe even
top five pick in the draft next year
if he was able to play similar to how he
played this last year
in in the covid year so i i thought that
he made a mistake having said that from
the
texans perspective they get a guy
that could potentially have that type of
talent and i think
does and they get him in the third round
albeit early in the third round but they
get him in the third round
i think from their perspective they're
thinking to themselves boy this was a
great steal
he comes from a pro-style offense a west
coast system under david shaw that's
very nfl ready
he's got the the the talent and the
stature to go out there
and play and if he's also got the makeup
like coach shaw suggests then this was a
great pick by the texans and i wouldn't
be surprised at all if he's
playing for the texans early in the in
the season because at this point
another thing that you know if you're
betting right now on desean watson
playing for the texans that's
that's a no-brainer that he's that he's
not going to be on the field for them at
least at this point
so they've got to move forward in a
different direction
joel cloud of fox sports here on the
rich eisen show let's look over the
steering wheel joel if you don't mind
because
you know the washington football team
did not get a
a quarterback of the future there may be
some other teams that are in that market
certainly
when i've got peter king on in hour
number two we are going to talk about
the fact that he's got the eagles
installed as a favorite
for desean watson to land as you know
the eagles have two first-round picks
a second rounder could turn into another
third first round pick
because of carson wentz's season um
if the dolphins aren't involved in
watson i know it's still
tour right there but maybe just maybe
there'll be some other teams that are
looking towards next year's draft
who's who do you got on your radar
screen that that might be
of interest to nfl teams right now
because
they they they gotta put their eggs in
next year's draft basket
yeah so i i well like i said i don't
think it's as strong as this class but i
don't think this
class was as strong as we thought it was
going to be you know
going into the year right so i would
start with spencer rattler at oklahoma
he's the most talented and and you know
he
he possesses the type of
arm talent that we see with zach wilson
i think that it's
it's maybe even a little bit more
refined from an accurate
accuracy perspective um he's got a
supreme level of confidence and i think
that he learned a valuable lesson
last year they struggled early in the
season and his first season as a starter
and and partly and and really mainly
because
of his inability to protect the football
and losses to iowa state
lost to kansas state and in the red
river game it was a game that gus and i
were calling actually against texas
lincoln riley sat him down and just flat
benched him in the middle of that game
and and
for that program that position to get
benched in that game
that just that's that's a dagger and he
came back
and played unbelievable the rest of the
year in large part due to the fact that
he was able to utilize
the offense if he learned that lesson
and continues that into this year i
think that he's
he's going to be a safe bet to be a top
quarterback in this class i think that
sam howell from north carol north
carolina is a guy that
is excellent now i have had a lot of
different coaches
throughout the acc tell me that they
were stronger running the football with
javonte williams
than they were throwing the football
with with sam howell so
that might be something that he may
struggle without that running
game you've got desmond ritter at
cincinnati you've got
um let's see keaton slovis at usc but
they're going to have to have big years
and prove
prove some doubters wrong to get up
there into that first round i
i don't think it's a it's a great class
but those are the names that you're
looking at
is rattler worthy of a number one
overall pick you think when it's all
said and done i think he can be
i think that he can be if he plays the
way
that i expect he plays and and this by
the way
this is going to be oklahoma's i think
this is going to be oklahoma's best shot
to get themselves out of that semi-final
into the national championship maybe
even you know that baker team that lost
to georgia in overtime that was a team
that probably could
have at least on paper competed for a
national title and
and i would have loved to have seen him
in that game but this is going to be
their best year if they're able to have
a season like that i think that he would
make a a serious push for that number
one spot it's going to be hard though
because
i i will i'll be honest there there's a
couple of guys like
kayvon thibodeaux the edge player from
oregon he
is a freak so i don't know if if
anyone's going to be able to
to tackle that top spot away from kevon
thibodeaux
joel before i let you go i got to have
you tell the story you know what story
i'm going to have you tell because you
told it to me on the set
chris brockman uh again i'm standing
there joel's telling a story before
friday night's draft coverage to dj and
charles
they rock their heads back laughing call
me over and they say joey got to tell
this story
so um i'll give you the floor joel um
you have it set it up
do what you will but my gosh this is
amazing go for it please
okay so um i i was fortunate enough to
play minor league baseball all right
and and i was just a young you know
bright-eyed bushy-tailed
guy that didn't know much because i
played high school baseball in the state
of colorado
i was drafted and then went right into
minor league baseball right out of high
school
and so my second year my second spring
training
um i was playing third base and the
padres had a third baseman in the
organization on the triple a squad named
sean burroughs
okay i don't know if anyone remembers
so this is way back this is you know
this is prior to 9 11 this is prior to
security and
social media so like spring training was
a free-for-all in the minor leagues you
could walk wherever you wanted you could
even go and like just watch big league
you know uh batting practice on and so
forth and so
it wasn't uncommon for a guy at a
position to be like hey i'm sore today
or i need a couple days
off and they would just be like hey go
take his spot on this team or that team
so
burroughs gets a sore arm and and
they're like hey we want to shut him
down for
three days or so so hey clat just go
hitting burroughs spot and play third
base for the triple a squad
during this week for spring training and
i'm like great okay so i just start
going with them
and literally the next day and burroughs
hit second back control guy
you know even though he's a third
baseman wasn't powerful so
he hit in the second spot the next day
the padres ink a minor league deal with
ricky henderson
[Music]
and i'm like well this is this is
interesting so
where does ricky go he goes the triple-a
squad where does ricky hit
lead off so there i am
second behind ricky henderson and i'm
in awe right i mean like that you gotta
understand my
i'm a kid watching those age teams i'm
looking at this guy and i'm like is
this real like somebody pinch me
and then everything that everyone's ever
said about ricky starts coming true
right before my eyes he's referring to
himself in the third person
right to my face like a dre looking at
me and being like
ricky get on and i'm like oh my gosh
this is incredible
you know so we'd be in you know getting
ready for our at-bat
and he would always you know he would
hit the donut off of his bat
just like you've seen and then he would
start tapping his toes and like doing
that almost like
the little shuffle towards the plate and
then he would turn to me
and he would look me in the eyes and
here i am you know this young guy and he
would just be like
two or three
and then keep walking and i was like
what in them
like what is he talking about i have no
idea and i was just like well
you know i just want to impress him so
i'm like man i'm i'm a power hitter
i just want to hit jax like just swing
as hard as you can joel like
you know like hit a home run so he's got
to wait for you at home plate so i can
give him
a bash brother like that's what i'm
thinking in my head i'm like oh it's
gonna be
amazing i'm gonna bash brother with
ricky henderson at home plate so i'm
going up there
and i am swinging out of my shoes
on every pitch and he keeps telling me
this number before every at-bat so
finally i go up to the skipper
jeff gardner and i'm like skip why
in the world does ricky keep telling me
a number
and he looks at me and he puts his arm
around me and i'm three days into this
guys
i've taken now you know 20 at bats
behind ricky
and he's like rook that's how many
pitches he expects you to take so he can
steal
[Laughter]
and i'm just like you've got to be
kidding me
that is just the greatest and he never
said anything to you like hey
i give you the number and now you're
just hacking for the fences
oh my god he never like
a and he would do it with the same tone
not like hey this time
like give me two he just kept turning
and telling me a number
like the same raspy voice the same like
just
three and then you'd walk
did you ever hear that walk up did you
ever hit one out did you no
never never not only did i embarrass
myself thoroughly
but i never even hit one out
joel i love that story that's one to
tell
i'm so glad you told it to us and thanks
for coming on the show as always
you're the best joel thanks thanks for
the time man have a good one guys you
got it there you go thanks joel clack
was that was that advertisement i was
not expecting ricky henderson
two two three that's the number of
pitches
so he could take second before he gets
before he goes before he gets to the
plate
he tells him how many he wants taken he
had to have been doing that his whole
career of course
absolutely he's ricky henderson yeah he
is an all-timer man he's
ricky henderson remember the snatch
catches
oh mm-hmm i was just every time he did
it
just he would snatch it out of the air
and just like oh my god
i had visions of the ball rolling into
the corner
because he took it and would fling it in
a different direction never once never
did
never did ricky
it's just the best of all time charles
davis told a story that he
uh um somebody told him
that ricky would collect his per diem
checks on the road
i've heard this yeah right he would
collect his per diem checks on the road
and place them in a bowl in his house
and whenever a kid comes to the house or
whatever and did a job for him
or one of his kids had a good week for
an allowance
pick out a check pick out a check
pick would you imagine if it was a
10-game road trip yeah you want that
that's the one and then of course it
would be just that one check for me like
a csi miami check
it out exactly hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here